What if we make a function that does all of that work up front and
then we just let the Van and the Cop class do a tiny bit of customization for
whatever is left to make them different from regular cars.
We would call this new function we're building a superclass.
That term includes the word class, because this function will be
creating a lot of similar objects and it includes the word super, because these
other classes will use the output from the superclass as their starting point.
Let's name the function Car,
since it's going to be creating objects that have the generic moving behavior.
And then Van and Cop will be even more specific versions of it.
Which parts of Van and Cop do you think could be moved up into the body of
the Car constructor function?